votaram todos os demais que vem
e os problemas a organização presta
estimulante iniciativa proposto falar de
portugueses conhecidos
isto significa que apenas um punhado de
deus estão aqui a ser educados dentro de
um conjunto de algumas centenas poucas
centenas de cerca de 200 250 nome que eu
cheguei no meu livro publicado em 2008 o
grande livro dos portugueses conhecidos
como tentar recuperar a memória um longo
cortejo portugueses cuja obra foi na sua
época esquecida vilipendiada associada
dessas faculdades poderão estar com os
vários de nós e inclusiva religiosos
políticos e essas obras diluídas um
pouco fim nas ruínas da nossa injusta
amnésia coletiva nesta quarta escolha o
movimento dentro dos limites possíveis
vou mostrar os alimentos exemplos de
contributos esquecidos ou ignorados de
intelectuais credores pensador civis
alguns idosos foram expulsos ou não
disse pra mim que uma existência neste
pequeno país neste ano a partir do
reinado amanhã 1º todos nós sabemos mais
ou menos 500 pessoas passando depois
pelos garis policiais britânicas torpeza
santo ofício enfim de um conjunto
intolerâncias que ainda foram praticadas
ao longo do século 19 português nesta
nesta condição e enfim nesta pequena
mostra do que normalmente o cortejo
deste portuguesas significa uma marca
muito impressiva nossa maneira de estar
e da nossa maneira de pensar naquilo que
nós chamamos ele vai ter reforma mentes
ânsia ignorância em intolerância três
vans isso são agrupados aqui nos modos
conflituais que
resultam sempre esse choque de minorias
inovadoras já mesmo que um destaque à
parte da manhã e o corpo meio da
organização
entenda como observar mais e ir assistir
essas inovações começar de imediato um
pequeno desvio das possibilidades que
escolher entre muitas outras
antónio luís nós tiramos voa cerca de
480 obter oral chegar lá em cima na
islândia assim uma vasta erudição
conhecedor das línguas latinas grego
hebraico é teve algumas dificuldades em
prosseguir a carreira acadêmica
problemas por causa da sua origem
judaica
todos nós sabemos da dificuldade
curiosamente este pensador original
trans hypado no essencial sonho no
essencial a teoria da atração universal
bonito - o movimento na sua essência que
não no seu desenvolvimento e suporte
matemático que só você ver de perto dos
finais do século 17 mas todo ano isso no
prefácio do segundo vôo ou do livro
segunda obra de alguns proprietários
foto e escreveu o seguinte é ter um
finalmente a afirmar que se acha
derramada por toda a natureza uma certa
força e tratativa que aprendi que um dos
seus com o nexo indissolúvel
esta força clica com invisíveis laços
com o mundo fazendo com que todas as
suas partidas posto situadas a
grandíssima as distâncias se companhia
nos seus lugares e deus não se rendem
ela faz entre se juntar coisas
semelhantes é o empenho da confusão da
ordem no universo
sabemos que pode atração de sal foi
apresentada apesar de nem em 1687 na sua
obra filosofia natural e dois pelo menos
que anthony luiz cliente se pouco amargo
é essência o conceito genérico que o
inglês
iria legislar sul exemplo antónio
andrade enfim entrou no noviciado dos
sunitas em coimbra que naturalmente
assim o habitual nesta colônia neste
recorte temporal e por último as missões
do oriente e quatro anos depois disso
para coxim em 1624 já na condição sobre
uma missão local partiu na companhia de
um colega manuel marques a intenção de
acompanhar o windows mobile se até délhi
andrade o companheiro aproveitar a
ocasião para fazer a jornada e alcançar
o que veste branca qual o twitter teve o
cuidado de verificar latitude e
longitude destas localidades
usando um instrumento capaz de vender
autor dos astros provavelmente um
astrolábio além de tapas de inclinação
do sol e sabia serviço de deus
apesar da extrema dureza da viagem do
clima da falta de mantimentos
imaginemos nessa altura ainda gostar
complicado
o diabo nojento nem pedras tempo estado
antônio andrada não faltou o compromisso
do seu encontro com o rei do tibete
empreendendo pois moção da viagem na
companhia de mais dois componentes
enfim andrade foi fato o primeiro
europeu a subir as encostas do himalaia
e transpor as suas montanhosas surgiram
as doadas morreu em 1634 quando se
preparava de novo para uma nova viagem
ao time o terceiro exemplo dentro do
moura portugal nasceu em 1602 frio que
antônio de andrade nasceu em oleiros
castelo branco em 1581 será uma evolução
cronológica paripassu em portugal nasceu
em 1902
efe a sorte de ser acarinhado pela
política cultural época por um jogo
quinto dentro dos possíveis estimulou
alguma formação científica encontrou na
época o jovem evento foi posto em
janeiro
desenvolver as suas qualidades inatas
invulgar sobretudo nos assunto
da mecânica eu sou portugal e teve azar
o nosso físico matou o jovem ficou foi
preso mas mora no set do forte junqueira
onde a ordem depois do marquês de pombal
acabou por finalmente finalizar se
quiser dos seus dias
durante o seu cativeiro em portugal e
ainda teve o discernimento para
descreverem mora e manuscrita cerca de
duas dezenas de utilidades umas maiores
outras nós infelizmente chegaram enfim
alguém que pode procurar esse manuscrito
e publicar esse nosso trabalho áreas
consideradas estratégicas espera que o
consignado os melhoramentos no reino
sobre tornar eleitoral hidráulica
engenharia hidráulica e foram imensos
sugestões que portugal deixou mais
eminentes e publicou inclusive um
trabalho nas atas destas senado disse
uma nota de ambas da inteligência do
país dando conta da descrição de uma
bomba o máquina de fogo uma versão
melhorada no engenhão criado com um
britânico em inglês e que se situa na
linha de aperfeiçoamentos e daí vieram
incorporar mais tarde a máquina do apoio
de portugal introduziu ainda e dança
professor menos na máquina pneumática
antas teve na alemanha e foi esvaziado
no sendo inclusive um deus
esta frase depois do grande delta na
inglaterra só o vento do moura
em portugal por exemplo
jacob rodrigues pereira é difícil
encontrar a verdadeira origem no lugar
de nascimento uma vez aqui no seu
emprego isso decidiram que nasceu em
espanha já feijão trânsito da sua
família para um beijinho nasceu em 1915
judeu de origem portuguesa foi pioneiro
no ensino dos surdos mudos e na criação
da linguagem gestual
já comprei estou sempre quis foi título
enfim de um sábio francesa notório na
época pagou e apresentou os resultados
então da sua linguagem
usando um jovem mulo aaron barr a sobre
o mundo nascença que em pouco tempo
aprender não só as letras mas também
articular algumas frases com a ajuda de
nossos mísseis ou métodos em crianças
portas que nada poderia pegar esse
trabalho nasceu a merceana as atenções
do vai do na altura luís 15 que mostrou
desejo principalmente da gol português e
chegou em atribuir uma pensão de 800
francos em 1751 nomeando interlegis das
línguas portuguesas espanholas e outras
marcas como os reis da suécia da
dinamarca receberam homenagearam e da
própria oi ao sair de novo aqui ainda
surpreende na nata em convencer o pai em
termos científicos da época também como
membro público o trabalho hoje sejamos
original em francês sou exatamente os
seus todas suas observações sobre os
mundos publicado em paris em 1762 é
considerado o primeiro trabalho
científico alguma vez escrito sobre os
surdos-mudos ea sua linguagem gestual
rodrix pra ir à está disputado no
cemitério judaico de vigilantes em
princípio não houve a sua pátria
um outro homem do tório notável da
história ele faria o famoso a bateria
usada com o personagem imortalizado com
o personagem na escrita leitura
universal por cédulas no famoso romance
ou com do mundo cristo nasceu em 1946 e
vai para lisboa na companhia do pai por
ter sido pai ter se envolvido nela
a famosa conspiração dos pintos a
primeira volta contra a autoridade
portuguesa no oriente assim é não foi
bem acolhido aqui na cordão de ouro e o
pai depois xii foi para o mano fez o
doutor em teologia mas enfim como o
ambiente na corte começou enfim é a não
ser muito favorável ao pai que era o
filho eu fui para paris em 1913 que
abriu empresa uma escola magnetismo
organizou um concurso público do chamado
sono lúcido e dirigindo e com as
tendências da época chamado mesmo prisma
o chamado magnetismo animal eu vai
introduzir isso com uma mediana clareza
uma ideia que toda a gente pode ser
solucionado por pode ser hipnotizado não
tendo nada de sobrenatural essa peça
essa capacidade de indução obviamente
não ser ver ações da dell e científica é
ecumênica presença no youtube mas por
outro ao conquistar a aristocracia para
isso todas as senhoras e portanto é o
primeiro grande trabalho primeiro olhar
sobre essa capacidade que hoje
aliás o nosso grande egas moniz tem uma
biografia sobre o lado faria e considera
o fato envolve o grande produtor ou anos
o homem que abriu caminho à chamada
hipnose clínica dos nossos dias
hoje aliás é permitir a importância das
primeiras experiências para o próprio
crescimento a psicanálise todos toda a
estratégia que vai ser usada por floyd
em viena e em paris e portanto esta
inovação no nosso lado faria marca facto
um caminho muito importante na área da
medicina roberto duarte silva nasceu em
cabo verde em 1937
começou trabalhando com o pai numa
pequena farmácia vai para lisboa
gravar a sua condição trabalhou também
em uma farmácia do jô
mas em vez do adversário pois a terra
natal partiu em 1857 para macau sentir
se mal com o clima e resolveu
voluntariamente exilar-se plantonista em
paris onde nos seus estudos determinado
e optou em licenciados em ciências
físicas passou a freqüentar os mesmos
laboratórios grande mestre francês da
química farmacêutica em 160 em 1870
quando é da guerra muito intensa entre a
humana e frança como sabemos os seus
pares dramático o time português foi
para inglaterra visitou o laboratório de
conhecer o método de trabalho
trabalhou com mais de várias
nacionalidades o ingresso é frança
trabalhou com a equipa de fridão na
escola minas profissional só homem e
desse trabalho conjunto iria resultar
acinte total da glicerina adriano paiva
faria brandão no extenso um homem nu
torna notável que nasceu em braga em
1947 coimbra passou a ensinar física em
1962 já na academia politécnica do porto
recebe hoje a faculdade de ciências o
núcleo essencial foi consciência e em
1877 apresentou já que estava em 3 até
nessa data os chamados princípios de
telas copiam elétrica tornando se assim
um professor da transmissão de imagens à
distância ou seja visa originalidade o
contributo do investigador requerentes
com os que consistiu na proposta de
autorizar o selênio como placas em cima
da câmera negra do telescópio cuja
aplicação se inscreveram
ontem foi publicado no comércio do porto
é meu em março 1878 chamada turbo linha
programa fia que elas copia e sistema de
captação da imagem do objeto afastado
foi então uma novidade os dogmas do
porto e 79 escreveu as teorias as
publicações o professor leandro paiva
que aliás tem nome da rua da nato
polímero senhora do porto santo na
escola filipa de lencastre concedendo
então a prioridade é invenção que pôs
aqui uma competição em termos de ontem
onde e quando se publicam os trabalhos
inovadores como é óbvio não é quem é o
primeiro
neste caso a viúva que uma concorrência
ecológica com o famoso xiii - amanhã
portanto grande pai está
indissoluvelmente ligado aos princípios
da televisão não antónio gomes himalaia
o meu último amanhã a última france a
homenagem deste curto castro nasceu em
árvores ou vez em 1868 de elevada
estatura foi deslocar smhadu do himalaia
por causa exatamente a sua estatura
eu gostava de estudar estudar a china
para paris um padre zé padre sendo
filmada porque nunca irá dar dos arcos
vai outro na selva licenciamento para a
construção deste ano da famosa que
conhece a famosa máquina soar o pelé e
ao filho que foi mostrado na exposição
dos saltadores no missouri nuno brandão
em 1904 segurando naturalmente a vitória
eletricidade cammesa início do século 20
onde a cidade é a rainha em poções com
as suas conquistas as suas opções
iremos inaugurando então aquilo que o
que será a seleção da luz
o sacerdote inventor para himalaia viria
a obter o grande prêmio com o respectivo
diploma assinado por cento e wilson
galera o acontecido duas medalhas de
ouro e uma prata
o protótipo do himalaia 4 até quarta
opção é o estado construir na inglaterra
a máquina ela atinge os 3500 graus
celsius graças aos seus 6177 para
descreditar o puro colocados no refletor
de forma de forma de parábola inc
então de uma quase tão indignada a
inesperada glória o padre himalaya viria
a acusar do patriotismo diversas
propostas norte-americanas uma delas de
350 contos na época para vender a
patente no seu laboratório
eu sempre disse que queria e pretendia
que a sua invenção fossem benefício da
pátria ps aqui como vemos praticamente
no rosto dos homens e estes contributos
espero que no futuro possa vingar
estas criações importante conteúdo
expresso da humanidade
obrigado